apple's new macbooks have smoked the  intel models they've replaced they've  smoked windows ultrabooks that cost even  more money they've smoked high-end rtx  graphics windows machines and now it is  time to put it head to head against my  15 000 mac pro let's just get right into  the carnage here now if we completely  max out the systems with cinebench's 3d  rendering benchmark mac pro does  actually have more overall performance  the macbook's 32 core graphics get 51  more frames per second for those of you  guys that edit photos when it comes to  export the mac pro does still win it  took a one minute 11 seconds compared to  121. at this point even for the toughest  tests everything we do the macbook beats  it in a 3500 package with the display  speakers webcam battery it's portable it  is just absolutely insane what apple has  done